The title of my
talk is demystifying
creating custom libraries
for your own organization.
And just like a
lot of our talks,
we like to go with long titles.
So I don't know if mine
like wins the long title.
Haven't counted it out yet but.
But Yeah.
So you know, when I was
thinking about this talk,
I was thinking,
you know, libraries
feel like they're like
reserved for more developers.
And there's this tough
thing that, you know,
is super difficult. You
have to read many chapters.
And what I found in
my journey, it's not.
And this talk could
actually be 2 minutes
instead of 20 minutes.
But just to hit
the requirements,
I put a bunch of fluff in this.
No, no.
I'm kidding.
There there's some
good stuff here.
So just going forward, you know,
my hopes from this presentation
is that you guys
all get inspired,
you know, inspired to
create your own libraries
and inspire other
people on your team
to contribute to those
libraries and those packages.
You know, before we
jump in, like, let's do
a little introduction of myself.
My name is Dan Caley.
My hobbies are hiking and
taking care of my dog Helmet.
That's him in a little vest.
I was hoping for a
little bit more oohs
and ahs when everyone
saw my dog, but all.
All, whatever.
We'll talk after.
I work at Custom Ink as a senior
data analyst and at Custom Ink,
and what we do is we
create custom t-shirts
for organizations.
And so we do that
because we're trying
to build community and
bring people together.
Just like this conference when
we got that RStudio t-shirt,
we're all 20% of the
people here are wearing it.
And it's bringing
us all together.
This company was
founded in 2001.
And I swear to you, all of these
people here look just the same.
And it's 20, 22.
So if you ever
work at Custom Ink,
they might have
discovered immortality.
I haven't confirmed it yet.
And this is, you know, this
idea of bringing us together
from a community perspective
is kind of the same thing
about libraries.
You know, we all
love these libraries.
We get involved, we
want to contribute
and there's a little
bit of community.
And so, yeah, so
like, you know, that's
kind of the theme of
a library or a package
at its core.
So the things that
we're going to be cover
is why package your
functions in the library?
Because that's
what a library is.
It's just a bunch of
functions, you know.
And we're just going to
briefly talk about functions
and how to create a function
and then create a library
and then documenting
your function.
And then how to
install your library
and how to install
your library is
going to be the important
part because that's
going to allow you
to share it either
via GitHub through
your GitHub's firewall,
or you can have it saved
in a local directory.
So Yeah, so you know why package
your function as a library? If you
ever had this internal
thought process, you know,
where did I save
that function again?
Like you're building something,
you create this cool function
and you're like, hey, I want
to use that function again,
but where did I save it?
Where did I put it?
What file?
Like, what folder?
Did I delete it?
Oh, my gosh.
That's like, that's scary.
You know, why can't
I find this function?
You know, you start spiraling,
you know, what did I do?
Did I save it in a
notepad or markdown?
Did I print it out and
then fax it to myself
like, you're going you're
going South, you know?
You know, I'll just
rewrite the function.
You know, it takes
you 30 minutes,
an hour or two hours
again to rewrite it.
And so this is the
idea of packaging
your code is that you want
to take those functions,
package them up so that they're
already in your R environment,
and then you can just load
them up and then use them,
and then also to
allow your coworkers
to use them and inspire them.
And maybe they're having
the same problems,
or maybe they didn't
realize that they
could create a function like
that because they're just
so busy.
So Yeah.
So I'm just going to
skip through this part.
So let's just cover what
a function is real fast.
So a function is a
set of statements
that when combined
performs a specific task.
So an example that
we're going to use,
and we're going to use
this function for when
we build our package,
So we're going to build
a "notin" function.
So for anybody who
use SQL, there's an "IN"
and a "NOT IN" and the IN function
filters on a list of values
and NOT IN does the opposite.
And that's nice
because let's say
you have a list, a
list of 20 things
and you want to exclude
only two of them.
You don't want to list out 18,
you only want to list the two,
so you can include the 18.
So in order to create that
function, all we're going to do
and it's really simple is
we're going to go negate in
and now we have our notin
function right there.
So we're going to use this
to create our library.
So what we're going to do is
we're on a clean R document.
We're going to go File
new package, new directory
in an R package right here.
And we're going
to call this "danalytics"
because my name is Dan
and it's my talk. Create package.
And then once we
create package, you
can already see there's
already some default things.
They have a Hello,
print Hello, world
which is just called Hello.
So let's just delete
that, let's remove it.
And you can see this
is just an R script
so you can have a
bunch of functions
that you already have in R
script and just plop it in here
and you're halfway there.
In this case, we're
going to drop our
notin function in here.
So we're going do
that, negate, in.
I promise you, I'm not
this slow at typing.
I go much faster.
And then we're just going
to do some housecleaning.
Let's rename it.
And again, my talk, not
yours, danalytics.
And then hey, great.
And we're going to go to the
top and build and then install
and then install package.
And that's pretty much
how you create a package.
That's it.
So if you have a
bunch of functions,
we're pretty much done.
And that's why I'm saying this
could have been 2 minutes,
but we have some other things
to do that we can add here.
So let's go to the next part.
So let's see if this works.
So we're going to load
the library, danalytics.
We're going to have attendees.
We're going to have Dan, Michael
or yeah, Dan, Michael, John, Andrew.
We're going to put
that to a variable
and then we're going to go
attendees in John and then
attendees notin John.
And as you can see
at the bottom it
goes false, false, true, true.
And it did the opposite.
And that's what we want.
True, true.
False, false.
So we see that the
notin function works.
Then let's just move
to the next slide.
OK, and this is a big part,
documenting your functions
and how you're going to do
that is pretty simple.
So there's this folder,
the man folder right there.
So we're going to load it again
and we're going to go to man.
And you can see in there
that there's already
a Hello file in there and it
already has some documentation.
So we can take that,
use that and replace it
with what we want to add, which
is going to be the notin.
And just like cooking
show magic, it's there.
And then what's nice about it
is if we just do the help or F1
key, we do help
and then notin cyou an
see there's some documentation.
And this is important because
sometimes your function might
be pretty complex and
you can document it
or you might have
to install libraries
that are outside
of your function
and you can all
document it there.
So it's easy for a user to jump
in and see what it's doing.
And then we already did that.
So now how do we
install this library?
And there's going to be
three options for us here.
We can either do GitHub public,
which anyone can access.
It's not through cran,
which is a little bit more,
a little bit more involved.
This is just free form and
that's not behind a firewall.
It's just your own GitHub.
And then either through
the GitHub enterprise,
which that one's going
to be through a firewall.
So I'll teach us how to
get through that securely.
And only like read access
and not write access
to that enterprise.
And then another one, a lot of
companies don't have github,
they have a file directory
and it's all shared.
So you can just save it
there and manage it there
and install it there and
allow your colleagues
to still access it.
So installing it from
GitHub public is just this,
you know, install package
devtools, call that library
and then install_github.
The developer name
and package name.
And so in this example,
install_github, dcaley5005 and then
danalytics and that's it.
And when you install
it, it'll just
look like a normal installation.
And this one's going to be
a little bit more steps,
but it's not going to be that
daunting as it might seem.
So installing from
GitHub enterprise,
we're going to install
this package, use this.
And then library use this.
And then what you're
going to do is
your whatever your GitHub
username is and your email.
In this case mine is daff.duck and
it's daffy.duck@funnyducks.com
and you're going to
create a GitHub token.
So what's happening
here is going
to use that config,
create_github_token is going
to use that configuration to
then open up a web browser
and then you'll log
into your GitHub
and it will bring
you to this page.
And here we would just
retitle it, you have notes,
this is the danalytic
package, and then you
can set an expiration.
You might want to set this as
90 days for security purposes
if you're ultra conservative
or if you just never
want it to expire.
And then there's pre settings
here that you can adjust,
but a lot of this is just
going to be read only.
So it won't let you
write directly against it
and upset your GitHub.
You don't want your
company to be mad at you.
And then where it's going to
take you when you scroll down
and you hit, yes,
it's going to
take you to here.
I blurred out this token.
I probably didn't
have to because I
deleted it afterwards.
But it's going to give you a
token where the blurry line is
and you're going
to copy that token
and make sure to put it like in
a shared password of some sort.
Keep track of it.
It's no problem.
You can recreate this
process and have a token
if you needed to.
And then you would just
do this just like before.
install.packages, devtools,
devtools, install_github
and then your company
name and then danalytics
and then whatever it is,
this is on the main branch
and then you would put your
token in there, run that,
and it would install
that package.
So then installing
from a file directory
is much simpler than that.
All you're going to do is go use
this right here in the devtools
you go install and then you
put the file directory in there
and ironically it is
put into a GitHub folder
for you then to download
it from a directory.
But yes, you just do that.
And then you can see if we call
the library danalytics it's in
and then you have access to it.
So I the notin function is
like probably not that exciting
in the function to use.
So I wanted to kind of give
some examples of some use case
that we use it over at
Custom InK. Connecting
to a SQL database.
You know, I think maybe just me.
I go online and I find
this all the time.
And this is from
the RStudio website.
Is this right here,
this whole credentials,
this is like 12 line of codes.
I have no reason why I
ever want to remember this.
I don't ever want
to remember this.
And so I created a
function called inkbase.
Custom Ink likes
to brand everything
our mascot's called Inky.
So databases are ink bases and
so created a function inkbase.
And then what we can do and
then set up some documentation.
And here you can see how
do you, what do you need?
You need to install
the package keyring.
The library is keyring and
then how would you set that up.
You go key_set.
So what's the
service that you're
using, which your username
would pop up and give you
a password that you put
in there that it secures.
And so it has some setup in
the documentation for new users
who have not connected
to a single database.
And then another thing
that I like is getSQL.
Just like when you
go read_csv,
this is the same thing.
I like to code in a
different IDE for SQL
and then save it down rather
than having maybe like
100 lines of a SQL statement or
1,000 lines of a SQL statement
in R, I'd rather have
it in a different file
and then call that file, read
it in, and then run that query.
And so I created this function,
which is like a getSQL,
and it's just takes
in the SQL file
and just takes it
in as a text file.
And so Yeah.
So you can see here we're
using this is no longer
RMarkdown, it's a qmd file and
so I'm going inkbase
for the function I
bring in RPostgreSQL
and then I come over
here and I go, OK,
I want to pull an order.
So I go to this
orders.sql file,
which is on the right
side right there.
I pull it in and then
I put my connection
in there, which is this
redshift connection orders
and then pull in the data.
And I can see that the data is
up there at the top right of R.
And then another
one that I like is
I love data tables when you
put them in R Markdown files
because then it allows users
to have visualizations and then
what's the data behind
those visualizations?
But one thing that
I want users to be
able to do once I give
them my RMarkdown file
is I want them to have the
ability to copy it or download
it as a CSV.
So maybe they can do
their own visualizations
because maybe they have some
other additional analytics they
want to do on their side.
And again, like, I would have
to write all of that stuff,
which I have no intention
to try to remember.
And so I created a
function where you can just
has copy CSV and then
the length menu,
you can just enter it
in there for the Y1.
You can say, hey, I want it to
be 10 pages or 10 rows long,
15, 25, whatever you want.
And that looks like this, where
you have the copy and then
CSV at the top rather than
having to remember all that,
I can just call that function.
And that is the end of my talk.
If you want to see
this, this is going
to be on the
rstudio GitHub page.
It's not up there now, but
I'll put this up there.